atlas paul's the greatest guitar ever
period
end of sentence for everybody that's the
best guitar in town and i'm in nashville
good does that work
hey what's up gq i'm jason isabel i'm in
my barn in tennessee
and these are my guitars
i'm not sure exactly how many guitars i
have i think it's somewhere around
50 or 60. the first guitar that i ever
owned was given to me
by my uncle my dad's old brother who's
in a covered band
i was probably eight years old seven or
eight years old
and he gave me this guitar he bought a
new guitar this was in the 80s
so he wanted a pointy guitar with a
floyd rose tremolo so he could
play like van halen so he gave me this
it's an electra
mpc les paul copy made in
korea but yeah i still have it i've
toured with it some for a while it's a
great guitar
i put a lot of stickers on it but other
than that it's in good shape
well this one's not necessarily special
other than the fact that it was mine
when i was a little kid
it was my first guitar because i didn't
have any money and somebody gave it to
me thanks to my uncle phil for that
but what i considered a special guitar
is
one that fulfills its purpose in design
normally on a guitar or an amplifier
piece of gear
if you're playing an electric guitar the
knobs should work
and if the knobs work really well then
the guitar is a good guitar and i know
that sounds over simplified but really
it's not
because you should have a wide variety
of sounds available once the guitar has
been set up and
the strings are the right distance from
the fingerboard and the pickups are the
right height it should play well you
know easily
and it should stay in tune here i'm not
going to show you on this i'm going to
put this one away
now i have a little bit better guitar to
make an example of these tone pots and
these volume pots
down inside there are potentiometers
that control
how much treble or how much sound
is allowed into the signal chain and
over time this guitar from 1953 so it's
60 66 67 years old what happens in those
potentiometers
especially tone knobs these two here the
condensation
humidity water gets into those pots and
causes the values of those pots to
expand
you know gibson guitar especially that's
that old has the potential to have
more high end more treble that's allowed
into the signal chain because of the
humidity that's condensed
into the potentiometer nashville is not
a place with a
terribly wide variety of temperature and
humidity not compared to some places
this building is uh humidified to stay
within a 50 to 55
humidity range i think that's the best
from what i can tell that's what they
keep the market guitar factory at so
that's that was how i set my criteria
for that
this guitar here i got in 1995.
it was new i was 16 years old i talked
to my
mom and gave me this for christmas and
it's a fender strap
plus deluxe so it had some extra
roller knife they call and then it's got
these aircraft aluminum
tuning keys and it had 80 sound and
pickups in it so i took those out and
put
vintage style pickups and bridge but
i've had this one since i was 15
yeah 15 16 years old this was the first
really good guitar that i got
you know i always got as many as i could
possibly afford
so when i started selling some records
you know that got out of hand pretty
quickly but
over the last year i've only bought one
which has been
a really slow year for me but that's
because a year and a half ago i bought
that les paul there and so i had to stop
for a while
okay so this guitar here is a 1953
gibson les paul i think all the goofs in
les pauls in 53 were gold tops
so they have this kind of like powder
gold finish that over the years
oxidizes under sweat firstly
clear coat on the outside of the finish
starts to check and then your sweat gets
in there
and causes that powder gold coat to
oxidize into a little bit of
green so on this guitar in the checks
and the streaks on the guitar you can
see the
color green from where arms have been
for many many years but this is a really
great guitar
the bridge on a 1953 les paul is
normally a really
screwed up sort of trapeze bridge where
it comes all the way from the bottom
and then it goes up really high because
it wasn't made for
strumming it was made for holding your
hand up here and muting
and playing in the style of les paul
which i don't do
and hardly anybody could do if they
wanted to anymore but this fella named
larry craig
who worked for neil young for many many
many years put together neil's
primary les paul old black also did this
to
daniel anwar's gold top which i think is
a 53 or a 54.
but he took the bridge off and cut this
part down this is the actual bridge on
the guitar
cut it down to where it's almost flush
with the body and then put the bixby on
it this is an old bixby from the 50s
you can tell by this curve right here
that it's an original old one but larry
hasn't done that to a whole lot of
guitars i bought this
tr crandall in new york city and this is
a really great guitar these
pickups p90s they were sort of the
original electric guitar pickup the
first one that ever really worked
have a very wide magnetic field so they
sound good really no matter where they
are pickups that came along later have
to be put in a very specific spot to do
what they're supposed to do
but these just sound great and they
sound like the 50s and they sound like
rock and roll
and they can also make a lot of noise
when you want to and this guitar plays
really well it's got a nice slim
neck and the fingerboard is very flat on
this guitar probably because originally
they were doing
finger style stuff similar to how chet
atkins or girl travis would play you
know jazzy sort of
uh 50s music now it just lends itself to
play
really fast if you play fast rock and
roll you can do it on a 53 less ball
but i love this guitar it's heavy but i
am too so i don't mind
yes there's a big difference in each
year really up until about
1988 or 89 could hand me in les paul i
could probably tell you what year it was
made if it's already
because there are noticeable differences
this guitar here this is called a red
eye
and this is 1959 las paul standard
sunburst 90891 that's a serial number i
got tattooed on my arm
this guitar belonged to ed king from
ben leonard skinner for a good long
while he passed away
i purchased it from his widow sharon
they live in nashville
and this is one of the best examples of
the most
collectible electric guitar ever made
in 1959 they just made a few hundred les
pauls
you know it out of those probably 300
350 are still around
and still in good shape it just sounds
like nothing else
plays like nothing else and sort of
defines rock and roll
jimmy page played one with led zeppelin
billy gibbons played one was easy top
joe walsh played one with the james gang
and eagles and
peter green played one fleetwood mac and
the same one for your green plate
wound up with garyvee and lizzy now kirk
hammond from metallica owns it they're
just really
historic pieces of american art
they go for anywhere from a quarter
million dollars up to
a couple billion dollars for 1959 les
pauls i think
her hammock paid 2 million for peter
green's this was not worth quite that
because it doesn't have that much of a
legacy but it's worth a lot
it's worth a whole lot yeah it's very
important to me you know anytime
when i don't have to do anything else i
get this guitar and play it and
it was stolen from ed king and bought it
i think from the original owner
and then it was stolen a few years later
from ed and recovered after a decade it
was without it for about 11 years and he
found a book a japanese book about these
guitars and there was a photograph of
this guitar in that book so ed
used that book to trace it back to how
it was
sold and who wound up with it and he
found it in a guitar collection on long
island a billionaire's
guitar involved and the billionaire just
gave it back to him after some
negotiations so
this one has a wider frequency range
and more options sonically so
on this guitar if i'm playing on the
neck pickup what gibson originally
called the rhythm pickup
and i roll the volume down it stays
clear
whereas on a new guitar that's pretty
rare and that's partially because of the
knobs and the potentiometers under the
knobs but it's also
just because of how the pickups were
designed and how they were built
in i guess the late 70s a few people
eddie van halen being one of the first
started taking these pickups these
humbucking pickups
and dipping them in wax to play really
super high volume without getting
feedback
you just dip the pickup and wax and let
it dry without
melting the bobbin and that's called
potting the pickups but back in the 50s
they didn't do that they didn't pop the
pickups so they have this sort of
open woody sound that almost resembles
an acoustic guitar a little bit even at
high volumes and high gains and this one
has a pretty special situation going on
because in kalamazoo michigan when they
were making these
very often they would just wind the
pickup until
it was full rather than count exactly
how many lines
of wire would go around the magnet to
make the pickup function they would just
keep whining and eyeball
it and throw it in a barrel and the neck
pickup on this one has about 600
more lines than it should have but the
magnet has
decreased in power over the last 60
years
so something very accidental about the
combination of it being overwhelmed and
under magnetized has made it perfect and
it's something that you can't really
replicate because it's a very
fine number of mistakes that went into
making it this way but this particular
guitar has a very special sound because
of that the one that used to belong to
peter green
he took the magnet out according to most
stories and turned it around
and put it in the wrong way and it may
have been an accident but because of
that that guitar sounds different from
any other guitar so
the time and the way these guitars were
built meant that they weren't all
exactly alike
and some are are better than others this
spot right here
this is the original red dye so it used
to be on these
sunburst lust falls there was a layer of
red that went all the way around the
outside edge of the guitar
and it was this color but it faded in uv
light and you actually
fixed that issue in 1960 but the color
they wound up with wasn't quite as good
as this one but the reds stayed on
so if you see a 59 less call chances are
there's not going to be much red left on
it because the sun would have faded
this one had a tag hanging off of this
toggle switch right here and it was in
the window
at the guitar store so everything faded
out except for this
red eye right here underneath the tag
mark ruffler's 58 has a similar spot
it's not quite as bright and mike
mccreedy's 59 he calls it dot and has a
similar spot
there are a few of them that are like
that but this was the most distinctly
[Music]
recognizable
[Music]
this guitar here is a les paul standard
sunburst
that was made last year 2019
by the gibson custom shop here in
nashville if you will notice it's
very simple it's a clone to this
let's fall here so here we have the
original
and then here we have the flow the
originals in my left hand
the clones in my right hand and as you
can see they're very very close
the neck if you can put your hand on the
net it's remarkable
how close they are because they scanned
it they have a laser scanner a 3d
laser scanner where it took about six
hours to scan the neck
to make them identical now there's a
little bit of difference in the color
of the red dye that's about the biggest
difference because the
inner line diet they're using in the
late 50s is extremely hard to replicate
and really hard to age this guitar will
eventually look even more like this one
they sound very very similar but still
this one's got the condensation in the
tone pot
that you can't really replicate
artificially
so they get as close as they can and
they can get pretty damn close
you know if you're willing to spend a
little bit of money this gets far
a few years ago gary bohannon who works
there at the guitar store
called me a couple weeks after i told
him i was looking for a telecaster said
i've got one here that we haven't put
out on the wall yet and you need to come
look at it before it goes up on the wall
so i drove over there and checked this
one out and
this guitar was made in april of 1965.
you can tell with fenders because if you
take the neck off what you shouldn't do
with the gibson but you can do it with a
fender electric guitar
because it's just bolting on these four
bolts you take the neck off somebody
signed in the pencil the person who put
the neck and the body together
and they put the date when they did that
so this was from april of 65
a little bit before april of 1965
the fender musical instrument
corporation sold to cbs
bob fender and they bought new york
yankees around the same time
and then in the summer of 65 fender
changed their
manufacturing to a more you know just a
bigger
corporate structure so they were under
the umbrella cbs so they started making
things more on an assembly line and
things weren't so
put together by hand so this is one of
the last sort of handmade
undertale casters from the 60s it's
candy apple red which is a
custom color original to the factory
where it was made
in fullerton california you can see
if you were to look close that there's
four layers of paint on this guitar so
the bottom layer
is a primer coat and then there's a
silver powder of gold
powder in the candy apple red and that
was
pretty much unique to 1964 and 1965
because they're constantly trying to get
that candy apple red color
exactly right so they have different
methods for how to do it also and i
think this is the real kicker
in 1965 before fender switched over
this place right here where the
headstock
meets the neck and the guitar has a
little bit more wood
it's a little bit thicker than other
telecasters
that came along before or after so it
adds a little bit more mass and it
causes the guitar to balance better
and to vibrate better and it makes it
sound better
and that only happened for a short time
because just a couple months after they
made this guitar
they started making them just about as
quickly as they possibly could and they
started cutting some corners and things
changed but this one
luckily was put together in the old way
the last call is a mahogany with a maple
cap i think it was eastern rock maple
which you can't get anymore that's
another
thing that makes it a little bit
different but fenders were usually
ash or alder and then you got a maple
neck here
and a rosewood fingerboard in the
mid-60s the rosewood fingerboard
was a veneer so essentially the frets go
almost all the way to the maple
so the rosewood is really just for looks
on this guitar it sounds like a maple
neck guitar which makes it sound
brighter
and has less natural compression on the
treble
in the early 60s like i have a strat
over here that was made in 1960 it had
what was called a slab
of rosewood which means that the threats
were going into roosevelt rather than
maple
the rose would absorb some of the treble
and made it a little bit less
painful but italy is supposed to be
painful so i would prefer this one to
sound the way it does
this is the stratocaster this is from
1965
and this is from 1960.
the strat is a more versatile and more
comfortable guitar
it has more contouring on the body the
telecaster is kind of two by four really
and then the strap was made so you could
hold it and play it a little more
comfortably
it has three pickups whereas telecaster
has two both are single coil pickups but
they're very different
in how they operate yeah the
stratocaster has this vibrato
bar which was sort of revolutionary
sonically
you know a telecaster sounds like the
edge
from youtube or like a country guitar
player like pearl haggard like uh
danny gatton most of your hot chicken
picking nashville stuff that's played on
telecaster and has always been then a
stratocaster was the
weapon of choice for jimi hendrix and
eric clapton just to name a couple so
you can get really
crazy and fuzzy and out of this world
with a stratocaster in ways that a
telecaster won't necessarily do but a
telecaster has a quality that's
almost banjo like it works really well
for country music
this guitar is just super cool i started
out playing with stratocaster
one i showed you that i got my own s15
16. this one's in 1960
all original when i got it i had a
switch
change done here and new
frets put on so it'd be a little easier
to play but other than that everything
is
stock and in 1960 1959 and 60 the strats
were very much the same as the les pauls
and they had that red
analog dye as part of their sunburst
finish
this one's faded completely no red left
on this at all it used to be three tone
1960 but but now it's two-toned 1960.
but yeah this is just
super easy guitar to play super
comfortable and if you want to sound
like
hendrix this is the way to go just be
careful don't put one of those little
clip-on tuners
on the headstock of the strap because
this sticker's on the outside
on gibson it's built into the headstock
the word
gibson so you can't pull it off but this
one if you use one of these little
clip-on tuners and you put it over that
decal
and you take it off you'll take the
decal off too and that decal has been on
there for 60 years i've never had the
guitar before
he pulled a little bit of it off with a
tuner right there that makes me sad
this guitar here i bought from dave cove
while we were working in the studio i
don't think he thought i was serious
about buying this guitar
he hadn't had it very long i said what
would you take for that 335
and he told me and i just immediately
went and got the money and brought it
back
it's a 1961 gibson es 335
and the golden era of these guitars were
58 59
60 and 61. and in 62 they went to
blocks instead of dots on the
fingerboard to mark the positions
these guitars just do so much they're so
versatile you can get a jazz sound or a
rock sound or
country sound and then they're
semi-hollow so they have a block that
runs through the middle of the guitar
so you don't feed back so much but then
they have their hollow on either side of
the block
so it has more open sound quality to it
but the cool thing about this is you can
play
clean and you can play something that
sounds like bb king
or you can play something that sounds
like led zeppelin on this guitar because
it's got basically the same
pattern applied for pickups that that as
paul has
remained 59 it's basically all right you
know i changed the tumors because the
old tumors were breaking off
but yeah 1961 i could honestly take this
guitar and play it
on every song for the rest of my life
and i would really be missing anything
this guitar would cover all the bases
this guitar is probably worth between
25 and 30 grand like the strat and the
telly those are about the same
that gold top's about the same they're
all somewhere around twenty five
thousand dollars
that let's call though it's probably
around half a million
you know i can't really have it close to
me without thinking that guitar is in
the room with you right now
the guitar is in the room with you right
now that les paul's the greatest guitar
ever
period end of sentence for everybody
that's the best guitar in town
and i'm in nashville i heard joe walsh
tell billy gibbons
that that's the best guitar in the world
heard it with my own ears
i'm not the kind of person who would
ever spend that ridiculous amount of
money on something for
reasons of clout or to make me feel cool
or
you know i know it's a terrible decision
and it's stupid and
selfish and it's ridiculous but i made
the mistake of playing that guitar
in the store and i got lost driving home
i couldn't sleep that night thinking
about it first i called my business
manager
and told her about it she's like no
that's ridiculous there's no way you can
[ __ ] do that don't ask me about that
again
so i hung up the phone and i called my
manager
tracy was over my whole career and i
said tracy i need you to do this for me
and you know i don't think i asked
anything major of her since i went to
rehab eight years ago but i was like i
need you to
find me x amount of dollars in private
shows
this year so i can buy this ridiculous
guitar
and nobody in my family or my band or my
crew
has to suffer because i've spent that
much money on a guitar so she did and i
wound up playing birthday parties for
bitcoin dudes and for you know big media
conglomerates and i said just no
no republicans and no qaddafi's and you
know and i'll do it long as they're not
hurting people
all day long i'll go play their [ __ ]
birthday party so that's what i did and
i took pictures
of that guitar on my iphone and when i
was playing at these
shows i would look at that guitar and i
think this is why i'm in someone's
backyard in front of a volleyball net
playing my very sad songs for people to
dance so it means the world
to me it really does outside of people
and relationships and
human experiences it's the most valuable
thing on earth
i mean i just love guitars you know and
when i was a kid i was playing my chief
copies of these guitars that i have now
and wanting so much to sound like my led
zeppelin albums or zz top albums
or clapton and now i can just plug this
stuff in and it's that time
because it's the real gear that they
were using back in those days so i'm
more obsessed with playing the guitar
now than i
was when i was a kid because i had all
the tools that i always dreamed of
i would never think of stopping buying
guitars you know
unless i couldn't afford it anymore that
then i would stop
i would still collect cheap guitars
though if i couldn't have nice ones i
would have 50 shitty ones
just because i like all different kinds
of guitars even the cheap
broke ass guitars you can do cool stuff
with to most ears
i could play a 300 guitar and a 300 000
guitar and it wouldn't sound all that
different but to me the
tiny five percent of difference you know
i can hear it just because i spend so
much time with them
and a lot of these guitars they don't
sound 20 better than
a cheap guitar they just sound five
percent better than everything else
for me that makes a difference it
inspires me more and it gives me more
direction and just more motivation to
play every day
i've got a couple of guitars that john
gave me this scratch
of white falcon from the baldwin era
probably made around
77-78-79 john trying bought this for
himself at a guitar store in town
and he told me it was because he wanted
to get up every morning and plug the
guitar into a big loud amp
and play a big e port and move the
whammy bar and he thought that would be
a better way to start off his day
than a cup of coffee and he said that
work for a while and then his family
sort of got over it so my wife got this
guitar from john for me for father's day
a couple years ago
definitely one of my most treasured
possessions yeah i mean it's a cool in
charge of really weird guitar it's wired
and stereo
so you know you can send it out from the
stereo cable
to two different amplifiers it's just
got all kinds of weird little quirky
things about it but i love it because it
was john's and because it is so strange
i got another grinch uh over here
it's a 1959 uh gretch
jet firebird that was given to me by
dave kyle after i use it on
southeastern and it sounds really really
good you know gretchen's are funny
because
now if you get one that's made new they
have sort of quality control going on
over there that they didn't have back in
the day
but in the late 50s and early 60s you
know you could play one branch and
be a fantastic guitar and then another
one would be a complete piece of [ __ ]
and just untunable and unplayable and
unusable and this one is one of the
really
truly special ones i think gretch
borrowed this guitar from dave when they
were
starting their new custom shop to sort
of model summary issues off of this
particular instrument but
it sounds fantastic and a good wretch
sounds different than anything else you
just can't
replicate this down to those pickups and
a hollow guitar
that doesn't have any holes in it you
know for example a really good
late 50s early 60s and listen to malcolm
young
you know his rhythm guitar parts on ac
dc records and it makes such a heavy
sound
out of actually a pretty clean tone you
know they're incredible instruments
when do you find the good ones this
guitar
uh was the first really nice vintage
guitar that i bought
i got it right after southeastern came
out seven and a half eight years ago
and uh it's a mid-50s martin d18
the golden era of martin acoustics is
before world war
ii so from the late 30s to the early 40s
it's the really collectible
very expensive era but hank williams and
elvis presley both played mid 50s d18s
and this one just spoke to me
immediately it sounds
really really good and the neck is nice
and fast and small
to get your hand around it you know i
think that for the money
50s martins are the way to go because
they've aged great you know wood dries
out over time and the guitars get super
lightweight
and then the kind of blue that they used
back then was horseside blue
so it was made from literal horses hides
and now a lot of people have converted
over to using fish glue
which i think works about the same and
you know you don't have to
contribute to the slaughtering of horses
for it so that's a good thing but the
horsehide blue would crystallize
and it would get super hard and so like
this guitar the neck is connected to the
body with horse hot
glue and that means that the vibrations
because that crystallized glue over time
has gotten so hard the vibrations pass
through it without slowing down very
much
at all and on a newer guitar that's put
together with a synthetic version of
that glue
the sound waves slow down because they
hit that synthetic glue and it's not
like glass it's not so hard so it causes
the sound waves to slow and when you do
that you take away from the
sound of the guitar my criteria for an
acoustic guitar is pretty simple
if it plays well and it's loud it's a
good guitar because
that's sort of a litmus test for
acoustic guitars the louder they are the
better they're built
[Music]
yeah an old martin acoustic they call
them banjo killers because
back in the day in bluegrass bands you
had to compete with a banjo and banjo
has a big
metal resonator on it and some banjos
are super loud as we all know
you can find a guitar that can keep up
with that
[Music]
you're doing pretty well and then martin
made a guitar
they still make the thing there's still
some of them out there but this is the
jason isabel
model v18 it's got my name in there i
wrote my name in there
well i wrote it on the sticker and then
they put the sticker in here and then
a tattoo that my wife and i share is
here on the 12th fret
but this one's put together with that
same you know louder is better
sort of ethos
and it's based on a lot of old d18s from
the late 30s
and then a little bit on that one there
from the mid-50s
i'm really proud of these i take these
on the road and tour with them and play
them
all the time they're really good guitars
cred green
martin reached out to me about making
the signature model guitar and this one
has a pick guard on because it's a
prototype and we just accidentally put
it on before they sent it to me but i
have another one here that's identical
to this one except it doesn't have the
pick guard i'll show you that one too
here we have the same guitar just minus
that pick guard so this one's going to
be about five decibels louder than this
otherwise they're pretty much identical
and these are that's my signature
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you